[Musique]
tu veux vous parler aujourd'hui ce qui
arrivait à marty martin de son vrai nom
à une chaîne youtube qui va vous parler
de teck de smartphone vous invite à
aller voir sa chaîne
je vous mets le lien en bas dans la
description et je voulais justement vous
parlez de ce qui lui est arrivé de
mésaventures de grosses galères et de
chose que j'espère nous n'arriverons
jamais et je voulais partager avec vous
d'une pour vous informer parce que on
n'est jamais assez prudent et on peut
toujours se faire avoir et ce qui lui
arrive et aurait pu m'arriver pourrait
potentiellement arriver de personnes et
je pense que ça arrive à d'autres
personnes puisque ce sont des arnaques
bien rodée et il faut le savoir et vous
faire extrêmement attention être
extrêmement vigilant et notamment en
termes de sécurité que ce soit là pour
sécuriser votre compte google ou tout ça
pour sécuriser n'importe quel compte
donc cette vidéo est là pour vous
informer mais également pour vous
partager ce qui est arrivé à marty c'est
galère et comment au final on a appuyé m
quelque chose qui est plutôt positif
et puis ça me permet également de le
mettre en avant parce qu'il a quand même
perdu quinze jours de visibilité sur
youtube quinze jours pendant lesquels il
a perdu des abonnés quinze jours pendant
lesquels il n'a fait aucune vue sur ces
vidéos et quinze jours pendant lesquels
et bien il y avait rien si ce n'est
beaucoup dans white de son côté par
rapport à sa chaîne youtube
c'est la toute première chose que je
vais vous invite à faire c'est bien
évidemment à aller voir sa chaîne à la
découvrir et puis si elle vous intéresse
que vous abonner le suivre comme ça ça
paraîtra lui donner un petit coup de
boost pour repartir plein de motivation
on va prendre le temps d'échanger avec
lui pour voir ce qui lui est arrivé et
comment il a réussi à résoudre son
problème je t'appelle martin martin oui
tout à fait je suis je m'en fous moi je
vais t'appeler marty sur youtube fall
marty saint martin ouais bien alors tu
es une grosse galère avec ta chaîne
youtube groupe piratage qui m'a foutu un
peu les boules aux médias pour resituer
tu peux expliquer qui tu es marty donc
ça fait cinq ans que je fais des vidéos
sur youtube et je fais tout ce qui
touche à la téléphonie
les tests les review et c'est extra et
j'ai quarante sept mille abonnés choix
ok rituel très bien et alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé ce que tu avais une
chaîne qui qu'il fonctionne tutu déroule
le contenu est un jour tu as une galère
qui reçoit un mail c'est que ce qui
s'est passé en fait pour qu'ils fassent
pirates et achètent en gros j'ai reçu de
mail
j'ai toujours pas à l'heure actuelle
lequel des deux mains à mahut est en
fait il me propose notamment de
partenariats et puis une fois que les
demandes sont cohérentes et logiciels
dont leur corps est également et à la
fin une demande du coup de batte de
télécharger le logiciel normale et sauf
que je reçois deux points exe et après
les deux points exil quand je les
télécharge je suis sur mon mac c'est
évidemment ça s'exécute pas et donc
j'envoie un mail aux deux mains je leur
dis voilà sur mon mac ça fonctionne pas
est ce qu'on peut faire quelque chose et
il sauf que je suis impatient comme pas
possible je me suis dit mon ils
répondent pas je vais faire sur mon
windows
et puis après sur windows ou pareil 2.1
ghz et que s'exécuter pas et le
lendemain je me suis réveillé et je
n'avais plus rien et c'est le lendemain
tu t'es rendu compte qu'en fait ça la
tâche n tu n'avais plus accès ouais
parce que bah déjà j'avais pas les
notifs créateurs sur mon iphone et puis
je vois que sur notre res mais j'avais
des mails de google me disant alerte de
sécurité etc et après j'ai vu mots de
passe a bien été changé c'est que l'on
était à double identification et bien
été retirés etc etc
et puis après quand j'étais sur youtube
j'ai vu que tout avait changé le logo
l'avenir et c est ce que tu tu as pu
savoir techniquement comment ça
fonctionne et comment les mecs avec
juste un point exeo ont réussi à
récupérer tes accès en fait attend quand
google attend vos pass
alors d'après ce que j'ai compris parce
que du coup j'ai un expert en
cybersécurité qui a vu le climat qui est
venu me parler sur twitter et il m'a dit
qu'en fait malheureusement c'était de
plus en plus courants sur youtube donc
vous faire vachement gaffe et que en
gros ça passait par les cookies du
navigateur et du coup en fait si c'est
comme si j'utilisais notre propre
machine ce qui fait du coup ils avaient
accès à tout ce qu'il y avait dedans
c'est un cheval de troie en gros si tu
veux sauf que du coup ça passait
complètement outre la sécurité de baupte
authentification outre les belles passes
etc
et du coup bah je l'avais dans lost
cheval de troie ils ont réussi à prendre
contrôle de tours navigateur et être
piratée tâche n est un et ils t'ont
piratés mais perd que talent chez elle
parce que c'est énorme ce qu'il ya autre
chose qui a été piraté une boîte mail
d'autres contenus
bah du coup la boîte mail qui était lié
à la chaîne mais sinon
sinon juste heureusement juste la chaîne
et la boîte make it il y avait donc en
gros un matin tu te lèves tu veux te
connecter attaché à nate et accepta plus
axa rien tu m'as sur la chaîne et tu
vois la tronche à neuf gars tu vois
honnêtement il avait effacé toutes les
vidéos ci enfin c'était tout maison
privée si tu veux mais ce moment je ne
savais pas d'où je pensais qu'ils
avaient toutes effacées quoi et qu'est
ce qu'est ce qu'y qu'est-ce qu'ils aient
avec ta chaîne en fait alors en fait
déjà essayé c'est autre chose qui est
encore plus grave c'est qu'en fait il
usurpe l'identité d'un autre gars qui
joue à cs go ils remettent en fait les
rediffusions de ses lives et il disait
je sais pas en échange du fait que vous
regardiez le live vous pouvez gagner un
skin exclusif en jeu ou je sais pas quoi
c'était juste des lives de cs go avec
plein de bottes parce qu'ils les 30000
personnes qui regardaient donc ça
m'étonnerait fortement que 30000
personnes de ma chaîne regarde ça qu'est
ce qui s'est passé après donc toi tu
vois ça tu vas contacter youtube du
sescoi parce que j'imagine que dans un
premier temps ce n'est pas arrivé je
touche du bois
j'espère que ça n'arrivera jamais mais
je suffoque tâche n tout le travail que
tu as fait pendant des années en un clin
d'oeil
il n'y a plus rien qu'est-ce qu'est ce
que tu fais directement qu'est-ce qui se
passe bano un premier temps je fais un
tweet mais en fait si tu veux le tweet
quand je le fais je n'arrive pas encore
à réaliser en fait que c'est vraiment en
train de se passer et que je me dis fait
j'ai vraiment pu rien pour moi si tu
veux je vais me lever
je vais les petits déjeuners je vais
aller écrire mes vidéos continue à
tourner etc
c'est après on fait quand je suis
descendu de cheval en parler comme
exemple j'ai réalisé ce qui s'était
passé et là du coup après dans la
journée donc juin que youtube dans ce
land le lendemain le bitume a contacté
seulement le lendemain et
donc du coup on parle un petit peu sauf
que c'est très très longue puisque après
on vous redirige à quelqu'un par mail
sauf que j'ai un ou deux mails par jour
puisque du coup je traitais directement
avec la californie donc bas desquels je
reste un peu long et puis ensuite on va
tailler elliott sous mes tweets
puisqu'en fait à l'aller sa chaîne qui
s'était fait pirater également il ya
quelques temps elle a eu un contact en
fait chez youtube via en outre youtube
heures sauf qu'elle pouvait pas me
donner ce contact là puisque puisque
confidentialité etc etc
sauf que du coup à la relier ma demande
à cette personne qui m'a fortement et
des cas une journée a tout fait
accélérer et en une journée
après j'avais tout récupérer bon après
deux semaines mais une fois que j'ai vu
le contexte de cette personne chez
youtube
il a accédé à toutes les démarches et
ses rails le soir j'avais récupéré ma
chaîne a suivi un peu l'histoire faire
twitter en voyant qu effectivement bien
ça n'avançait pas ou pas par patate
était prêt à dire je vais recommencer
une nouvelle chaîne youtube je vais
repartir à zéro
d'ailleurs tu mets 5 ans à construire
une communauté c'est énorme tout le
travail toutes les vidéos que tu as fait
derrière tu te disais quoi je vais
repartir à zéro je vais repos des mes
vidéos
est-ce que je vais du coup pour
commencer une nouvelle vidéo par
nouvelle vidéo c'est quoi donc pas telle
qu'est ce que tu deviens ce moment là
honnêtement je me voyais pas arrêter des
vidéos parce que j'aime trop ça et que
vous ça fait cinq ans maintenant c'est
une habitude c'est quelque chose que je
fais tous les jours et j'adore ça mais
en même temps je me dis faire une
nouvelle chaîne c'était quand même
enfin ça ne pose aucun un groupe à où
coeur située la qualité de choses qui se
sont passées les dons de passe etc
quand je vois jamais tourné de notre
métier dit je vais seulement remettre je
pense mais testent depuis depuis sept
ans par exemple et puis ensuite la
nouvelle vidéo et ses drames et j'étais
prêt à recommencer mais je peux
toutefois face une audience que youtube
on repousse un peu tâche elle était
minime homme de vue c'est repartir à
zéro c'était plus tard sur quoi ok donc
apte à tous récupérés dont classe et
j'ai pu tout récupérer tous les culs
périple encore une fois grâce aux mecs
chaîne youtube
donc heureusement qu' il n'avait pas il
n'avait pas plu contrôle de moi à 100
parce que là j'aurais pu j'aurais été un
peu dans la merde et
par contre j'ai vu que avec mon adresse
mail les effets du coup les transactions
à bitcoin pour acheter ma chaîne
jusqu'en fait en gros elles sont piratés
et ensuite ça doit être vendu sur le
dark web pour être rachetés en bitcoin
est en échange de du coup d'argent
effectivement et dont j'ai vu dans les
mails de toutes les transactions qu'ils
avaient fait pour racheter ma chaîne etc
il avait même pris le nom de domaine
pour un site se faire un site avec ma
chaîne etc
donc j'ai eu toutes ces informations
après dans mes mails quand j'écoute maxi
chop et cusset où était situé le mec qui
a piraté
ouais à new york aux états unis dans
l'état de new york dans l'état de new
york
donc tu as un mec dans l'état de new
york qui a piraté theissen grâce à ce
cheval de troie et qui voulait faire un
business derrière et se faire de
l'argent avec tournante acolytes avaient
déjà créé là je comprends pas trop
l'intérêt
parce que le mec c'est live le sachet
dont il y avait ses bottes au début donc
ça faisait beaucoup de personnes mais
bon après y avait plus personne qui
regardait du coup j'ai eu beaucoup de
désabonnement aussi connaît maintenant
je vois pas trop l'intérêt du mec en
question qui a racheté la chaîne
combien d'abonnés pas perdus paribas
quantifier ou pas à l'heure actuelle
alors j'ai des stades qui sont pas
encore actualisé mais j'en ai perdu
entre 700 et 800 et à des gens qui
tombent écrit sur twitter qui fait ta
chaîne qui disaient qu'est ce qui se
passe avec ta chaine tata change étude a
été piraté tu as eu des messages
il ya des gens qui vont me dis qu'est ce
qui se passe quand vous voyez du cs sur
ta chaine pourquoi le bo a changé pour
le nom a changé subitement j'ai même des
partenaires des partenaires qui m'ont
envoyé des messages en disant voilà ce
que c'est normal que tu as chaîne
échanger comme ça on trouve plus tâche n
comment on fait pour les projets à venir
etc etc
donc oui j'ai connu pas mal de gens qui
sont venus vers moi après derrière pour
me demander ce qui se passe est bon
d'accord il est ce que tu as eu des gens
qui y mettant la chaîne est revenu sont
venus frères bonnet attachés à des ce
que tu as des messages d'encouragement
des gens qui sont bas qu'ils étaient
partis qui reviennent t'arrives à
mesurer sa un peu après j'ai gagné
beaucoup de choses que beaucoup de gens
finalement ollier mais twitter relayait
mes tweets sur twitter
du coup j'ai eu beaucoup de choses par
rapport à ça donc j'ai des gens qui
découvrent et il ya des gens qui revient
effectivement ils disent qu'ils aiment
assez cool je suis contente de le
retrouver et après j'ai vu qu'il ya
aussi beaucoup de gens qui avaient été
des abonnés tout seul de ma chaîne en
fait d'accord donc j'ai eu des messages
en me disant tiens c'est bizarre j'ai
été plutôt bonnes attaches n
pourtant je te suivait depuis un petit
moment et voilà donc je sais pas trop ce
qui s'est passé mais là ça commence à
revenir doucement
écoute moi j'avais tout le monde à venir
s'abonner à sa chaîne pour découvrir ce
que tu fais puis de soutenir parce que
quand tu te tapes une période comme ça
avec des galères à te dire mais comment
je vais faire dans plus de ça en termes
de ne serait-ce que de faire évoluer la
chaîne de partenariat tu me parles de
partenaires tu peux rien faire des blocs
était une vraie difficulté d'anticiper
ce qui va pouvoir se passer c'est hyper
anxiogène donc je vous invite à
découvrir la chaîne de marty et allez
vous abonnez vous même thiviers en bas
dans la description mais écoute j'espère
que ça va aller et puis surtout que ça
recommencera pas que tu te refasse pas
pirates et h1n1 nouveau nom alors qu'est
ce que tu dirais toi qu'est-ce que tu
donnerais on conseille maintenant à
toutes les personnes qui ont des chaînes
youtube et qui potentiellement bains
sont comme moi d'ailleurs à recevoir
beaucoup de partenariats beaucoup des
mecs comme ça et à dire on est tous on
peut tous qu'est ce qui te faire pirates
à mme morano en tout cas un vrai j'ai eu
des trucs qui j'ai des recommandations
sur twitter ce qui n'était pas forcément
idiote de par exemple tester les
logiciels dont des sandbox donc comme ça
pour voir que logiciel apathie russie a
pas de trucs comme ça dedans si tu veux
ça et puis va vraiment être très
vigilant parce qu'en fait moi si tu veux
je pense que c'est le deuxième logiciel
qui m'a piratés parce que le deuxième
est arrêté on a été propre etc
il y avait je pense pas dangereuse de
retourner de vigilance même si dans un
premier lieu celles avec des gens de
confiance toujours rester vigilant et
après les antivirus etc les terrasses
après forcément puisque le bal à tout
est passé outre à chaque fois donc voilà
vraiment rester très vigilant et
toujours bien vérifier tester le
logiciel avant dans des virtual machine
du midi pour pas corrompre ou son
ordinateur
bon écoute merci à toi à merci de ton
témoignage ce fait bon courage que ça
recommence pas une on s'étonnera pas
inquiet non avec grand plaisir et puis
bonne continuation et puis à très
bientôt alors merci à toi aussi
[Musique]
je sais que
et
soit
elle avait